anything anything I can help with or
answer any questions anything of that
nature
[Music]
okay so I'm yeah of course so I'm I have
a presence on weibo and wechat and if I
could pull it up and I'm also doing
quite a bit with um with a face book
Chinese page that is actually growing
ridiculously well and so in general it's
not saying that um in general to me I
think about things in 30 and 40 kind of
year windows and the thought of not
having a presence in mainland China is
almost like not being not existing Oh in
that kind of window and so I'm doing Kol
collaborations with people who are
trying to build a presence in the US or
rest of the world and obviously two core
things that I speak a lot about
entrepreneurship and really I would call
it family dynamics of psychology of like
what twenty to thirty year olds go
through are clearly over-indexing
subject matters in you know for a lot of
mainland Chinese youthful entrepreneurs
and so it's really really growing very
rapidly
to
you kidding about how do you train
and not to me too
Phil advice I've received original
traditional Chinese
all that education but point of view so
in mainland China anyone ever no I don't
think there's I don't think they've said
it in the US either or Europe for that
matter and it's interesting right like I
think I think about it in two ways I
think there's two ways to win your 20s I
think you either go all-in and like work
your face off and build that foundation
or you go completely in the other
direction and you go higher risk higher
reward to China just figure yourself out
and taste a lot of different things yeah
I mean you know it's actually it
actually is it logical or practical the
way that we're all brought up and like
how we're supposed to address 22 to 30
it's supposed to be like okay go attack
and like settle it down and build a
foundation it just doesn't it it had a
lot more merit when people live to 50
years old
it just doesn't you know it doesn't have
as much merit in the way the world is
today and the opportunities that are
gifted yeah I mean I think a lot of a
lot of the things I think about
challenge conventional wisdom because
what I think I tend to do is layer the
reality of the current world and not
just think what used to work in a
pre-internet industrial revolution
you know 1960s 70s 80s world I'm
thinking about the tips for us I think
that we have to be like renewing
ourselves every day on social
and as every other company - and
yeah we're doing campaigns were doing
inspirational content and so on but have
what are the teachers like from your
perspective what should we be I do the
number how do you see like commercial
candidates on social so the thing that I
think will make sense to you guys is
that I think that a company like little
homework for this meaning I think they
go they get fragmented too much meaning
in social it is either things like Dane
and day of content to fill the pipes
which is aspirational and nice and maybe
spending too much time worrying about
engagement and not enough time about
what the business results are and then
they spend a lot of money on outdoor and
television and traditional branding to
me the biggest opportunity and social is
doing brand work inside of Facebook to
me the number one thing I would do if I
took over marketing is I would produce
you know 50 second to four minute videos
for Facebook with the intent of brand
and sales long videos mm-hmm I think
because they work quarter videos work
for the vanity metrics of social media
and the way you you kind of judge you
know shareability or consumption but
when you look at actual attribution to a
transaction or the ability to let's play
it out okay so you make a twenty second
video on Facebook it gets me you know
let's say it gets a hundred thousand and
engaged like shared commented and then
you run a two minute nineteen second
video that has a lot more breadth to
like what you're about that one may have
17,000 people watch it it may cost you
more money on media to get 17,000 to
engaged in the hundred thousand but when
you go to retarget those 17,000 versus a
hundred thousand to buy the math tends
to work out on the smaller deeper group
then the wider shorter group and so I
think that what's great about being
unlike being a bottled water company is
when they go to retarget there's still a
retailer and they can't see all the math
for you when you retarget it's black and
white you'll be able to see the CAC and
the LTV on the transaction that you're
looking for and so I think the biggest
mistake a lot of big companies make is
they do social media for the sake of
social media not for the sake of the
actual business goals they have and they
don't hold traditional dollars they
spend to the level of accountability
that they do in the new world because
the new world has so much more metrics
you have no idea if there's 3 second or
10 second viewability on your
commercials you don't know the
impressions of your outdoor you've
accepted it because it's always been
done but you hold the new stuff to a
level of scrutiny that you don't the old
stuff so to me that's where the big
misses for how do you see like very
tactical
advertisement even in social media
should also be done for
I think both work I think branding and
selling work I mean there's an enormous
amounts of selling to be done on
Facebook I think you can't be half
pregnant I think a lot of people try to
hide sales into branding and vice versa
I think there's a there's a lack of a
good conversation between the difference
between a piece of content that's meant
for branding and one that's meant for
sales and I think most organizations
over-index
in respecting one or the other you have
some companies that only don't like
social media because all they want to do
is actually BD are marketers and that's
why they favor Google and then you have
other people who don't value social
media because all they want to do is
brand work and they think television
where sponsorships are better brand work
and that's why social and specifically
Facebook has this incredible opportunity
right now because it's under priced
attention because not enough money is
going into it either from Dr or brand
yet if you look at wish if you look at
so many other companies they do their
marketing and they're selling purple
mattress many other companies Lola in
that environment that's why I'm so
bullish on it the issue is like anything
the ROI of this of these two markers is
completely predicated on my talent to
draw with these two markers and I think
that you know there's a sophistication
both mathematically and artistically and
strategically and psychologically that
it takes to be good at any marketing in
any medium and I think most people are
applying old principles into this new
environment which is why they're not
getting the results to your point this
bottled water company would rather put
something like you know a what a hashtag
Wednesday wisdom post because they're
gonna get 87 likes on you know on the
post without really understanding if
that's gonna lead to selling here I
think there's a lack of thoughtfulness
in most people's you know overall
digital overall marketing strategy
digital strategy and then social
strategy
when you were looking at our like
Facebook site what did you think what I
couldn't F what what I was looking for
more was how much marketing you were
doing actually in a traditional world
when I was looking at Facebook the
biggest thing that I don't know is are
you running Facebook Ads that I don't
see you know which I would hope you are
and more importantly is far more
important than what I would see I was
less say analyzing your social I was
more trying to get a sense of how much
traditional media you were doing in in
the name of branding because as I've
just said earlier the number one thing I
would do if I were you is do much more
branding inside of Facebook that to me
is that to me is the you know the you I
would argue the unique point of view by
comparison to most right now that I
think has the most upside did you have
like because what do you think about
what ascend and artificial intelligence
now but it's like talk a lot but it's
being taking those like books very
seriously they have been doing good work
inside messenger and so on we are there
yet we have you need to get there you
need to get you're gonna get caught if
you fall behind too much because all of
your customer service is gonna happen
through that environment yeah you're
gonna save a fortune yeah it's gonna be
better more efficient higher conversion
and lower cost you need to be serious
about messenger and I think when you
look at mainly in China the u.s. BK and
Russia the AI message bot infrastructure
is going to be very important consumers
will reach interact with those BOTS
because they're gonna get time-saving
it's gonna take time it's gonna take two
or three years for it to be the behavior
that I think a lot of technologists are
looking for but I mean I'm a very big
fan of of it and will be there
I think everything should be in house
which is funny considering what I do for
a living I think what I've learned is
that most companies aren't are the
reason they don't do in-house is two
reasons one strictly from a Wall Street
or publicly traded company standpoint
they don't want the expenses on their
P&L which hurts them in public markets
or - they just don't retain the talent
and they feel like we take you know they
lose that continuity to me anything you
can do in-house is always going to be
interesting unless there's somebody
who's hungry enough the way I would want
if I owned a company the way I would
play agencies is I would work with
independent shops who are on their way
to try to sell to holding companies
because they're gonna care more they're
just different so I think the biggest
issues with agencies and with brands is
agencies are publicly held companies you
know so much consolidation that I think
that's right but I also think what
agencies do do well including others is
they're able to see your brand in a
different way than you are everybody
thinks their kids are the prettiest so I
think that's where they can they can
bring sensibility my biggest problem
with agencies is they don't produce
enough work for the cost associated I
think that's where we're really kind of
winning is we're first of all I've built
the agency mainly to buy brands so I
have far more ambition to become my
clients than to be an agency which
aligns our interests better and what we
realized after we got great at media was
oh my god we have to produce so much
content to take advantage of the media
landscape so we built our own 50,000
square foot production facility and have
had a much deeper religion on the cost
of creative that I think the market has
been accustomed to without giving up
this magical idea of quality you know
when I first got into the business you
know I came from startup land and
entrepreneur land in Silicon Valley and
I would look at a video
you know commercial and I literally was
like how the hell does this cost six
hundred thousand dollars you know I just
couldn't get there I so I think our
great ambition back to the show our
model is if you're a brand that does a
commercial and it costs eight hundred
thousand dollars in out-of-pocket and
creative and production we try to
convince that client to do six or five
or four or three long-form Facebook
videos for that same cost which can
first fit different demographics right
because when you do one commercial it's
just vanilla whereas you know if you if
you star an Asian you know family and
their 20s and target Asian American or
Europeans in their 20s you're gonna over
index in relevance and then we also
think the media costs of distribution
are more efficient because I think the
biggest conversation that you also
probably want to have on the media front
is there's potential reach and then
there's actual reach and I think the
market trades on potential and doesn't
layer common sense I mean there's almost
no market left in the world that OTT
hasn't eaten up such a substantial
percentage of television content
consumption that it's made every
commercial reared
grossly overpriced
yeah what's a small-market sit yeah
over and over yeah I think I think the I
think to your point one thing I did look
at and I had a meet up last night with
four of the ten faces yeah I think
there's a lot to be left desired in
influencer marketing but I think I think
that's where you probably want to look
at the global nature of your business
and look at the pockets where it where
you can play or using those same faces
in other markets so I do think they're
inexpensive so I do think what's
interesting about your ten faces is in a
us-centric campaign with that kind of
level of YouTube which is really what
we're seeing following there probably is
an inexpensive way to do some very
clever collaborations where you might be
able to take those four to ten do some
sort of collab with two or three
us-centric in the US there's something I
think that would really work for you
which is family vlogging is very big and
some of it can get pretty affluent but
uh and I could see a lot of interesting
collabs of like that family going to
there's something to be done that I
think you could hack so I think if
you're thinking for this market the
domestic market I I would say how
underpriced Facebook and Instagram ads
are is probably the strategy I would
deploy if I thought about the influencer
market I would use them as ambassadors
on the outside because what's great
about YouTube is this let me play it out
for you you take a youtuber it hundred
thousand subscribers he's still cheap
like you can like you probably give him
a couple of pumped or fine a little bit
of bucks but in the ecosystem of YouTube
if there's people with a million
subscribers in the US the idea to do a
collaboration with him is exciting
because they want to siphon fans from
him so he's more valuable as an asset
out there you see where I'm going and
this is what I was talking about with
thoughtfulness I think the level of
sophistication and the way that people
fragment all these different things and
that's why I think we've invested so
much in strategy our biggest growth has
and so we used to beat somebody like you
but if we wanted to do business we're
like okay you can give us your media
budget you can give us your creative
budget and I think the thing that we've
realized the last couple years is or for
a hundred fifty thousand euro strategy
thing we can save clients millions of
dollars with their creative and media
partners and it's a good way to get the
value out of us so I think even how
we're talking now that would have been
how we probably would have analyzed your
influencer strategy go use their
following count to do collaborations in
other markets with bigger influencers
who are trying to siphon and use them as
a gateway as an ambassador to your brand
through that collaboration to me it's
unemotional assets versus costs right so
for me I'm not in love with Facebook
Miriam I'm in love with the price of
their ass
[Music]